in this video you're gonna learn how to
find the area of a regular polygon we're
going to talk about when you're given a
radius or you're given the perimeter or
a side length or the apothem but first
let's talk about where do these formulas
come from and how can we use them to
find the area of a regular polygon so
the first thing is say we're given a
regular polygon like this
what's a regular polygon well a regular
polygon means that all the sides are the
same length they're congruent and all
the angles okay are going to have the
same angle measure and so what we want
to look at is we want to take this basic
figure and we want to divide it up into
triangles and so you see how I'm drawing
these radii and the reason I'm calling
these radii is because imagine if this
polygon were inscribed okay scribe means
to draw or write we're in scribing or
drawing it on the inside of this circle
where the vertices lie right on that
circle so you can see I drew these five
radiuses here because this is a Pentagon
and what we get here is what's called a
central angle and all these central
angles are going to be congruent so if
you want to find the measure of that
central angle all you have to do is use
the formula 360 divided by the number of
sides or the number of central angles
and that will give you the measure of
that central angle but what I want to
show you is if we know that all these
triangles are congruent what we can do
is we can find the area of one of these
triangles multiplied by how many we have
and then will give us the total area of
the regular polygon now we know the
formula for area of a triangle right
it's one half the base times the height
so the base would be like the bottom of
the triangle like this is your base
right here and the height would be how
tall the triangle is like that but in a
regular polygon what we do is we call
this perpendicular distance from the
center of the regular polygon to the
side the apothem okay so we use the
letter A for your pathum so instead of
calling this the height I'm going to put
a four apothem and then the base see the
bottom of the triangle here we call that
ass that represents the length of the
side so I'm going to call this s and
then we've got one half so instead of
1/2 base times height we really have 1/2
s times a and remember how we said if we
find the area of this one triangle and
multiply by the number that we have
that'll give us the area of the whole
polygon so what I'm gonna do is I want
to multiply this by n meaning ends the
number of triangles or you can think of
n as the number of side lengths okay cuz
however many sides that's the same as
the number of triangles and now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to rearrange
this formula here because remember
multiplication is commutative you can
change the order and you'll still get
the same answer when you're multiplying
so I'm going to rewrite this as 1/2 a
and s so you can see that's one of the
formulas that students typically use
when they're finding the area of a
regular polygon but what about the
second one here area equals one-half
apothem times perimeter well we know
that the side length multiplied by the
number of sides is the perimeter right
so here if I just group N and s together
n times s is the same as P and so that's
where we're getting the one-half apothem
times perimeter now we're doing some of
these problems we may have to use
special right triangles like 30 60 90 or
45-45-90 triangle as well as some
trigonometry like the sine cosine and
tangent so let me erase this let's jump
into the four examples pause the video
see if you can do these on your own and
we'll work through them together number
one we're given a regular hexagon
hexagon means that there's six sides all
the sides are congruent all the angles
are congruent so a regular hexagon how
do we find the area well let's go to our
formulas here one half ans and or one
half a times P whichever one you prefer
I'm going to go ahead and use the one
half a and s so we know the side length
okay that's going to be 10 so let's go
ahead and put that in place of s okay
and we know the number of sides that's
going to be six sides that's going to be
six and now we have to find the apothem
so apothem remember we drop a
perpendicular to this side and what
happens is it's going to bisect the side
okay so it's going to cut it in half so
these are the same they're both going to
be five and I'd like to draw this as a
triangle like this now when you think
about these regular polygons remember
how we talked about how you can break it
up into congruent triangles and you can
see that there's actually one two three
four five six triangles so if I take 360
divided by six
that gives us our central angle of 60
degrees which is right here but when I
drop that altitude which is the apothem
it's going to bisect this angle so that
means that this is a 30-degree angle
let's go ahead and draw this triangle a
little bit larger so we can see it so
this is a 30-degree angle
and this side length is 5 because we cut
the side in half and we're gonna go now
to our 30-60-90 special right triangles
so if this is the short leg the one
across from the 30-degree angle which is
5 how do we get from the short leg to
the longer leg well we have to multiply
by the square root of 3 so this is going
to be 5 square root of 3 and that sort
of pathum right there so let's go ahead
and put that into our formula and now if
we multiply all this together we get 6
times 10 is 60 times 1/2 is 30 times 5
is 150 square root of 3 so that's an
exact answer 150 square root of 3 inches
squared because it's area and you got a
number to see if you can do this one we
have a square okay which is a regular
quadrilateral inscribe inside of a
circle with radius 8 centimeters so how
do we find the area of this square well
let's go ahead and go and write down our
formula again area equals 1/2 a times n
times s now I like to write the formula
down first then I can kind of figure out
what I need what's missing you know etc
and I can just kind of keep it organized
so you might want to do that but the
first thing I like to do is I like to
divide this up into congruent triangles
like so and you can find this central
angle again remember by taking 360
divided by 1 2 3 4 angles so that means
that each one of these central angles
here is a right angle 90 degrees now if
I drop an altitude okay which is going
to be the apothem of the triangle
it's going to bisect this angle here so
that means that each of these is going
to be 45 degrees which means that this
triangle right here is a 45-45-90
triangle it's a special right triangle
so how do we go from the hypotenuse to
the leg okay of this triangle well you
can see the hypotenuse is X root 2 we
have to divide by the square root of 2
to get to the side length so that's what
we're gonna do here we're going to take
8
/ the square root of two we don't want
the square root in the denominator we're
gonna have to rationalize by multiplying
the numerator and denominator by square
root of two so this gives us 8 square
root of 2 square root of 2 times square
root of 2 is square root of 4 square
root of 4 is 2 and then 8 divided by 2
you can reduce this comes out to 4 root
2 so this is 4 root 2 the apothem is
also 4 root 2 and if this is forward -
this is forward - because the side is
bisected by the apothem okay so now we
have some more information to put into
our formula so the apothem we said was 4
root 2 the number of sides is 1 2 3 4 -
square so that's 4 and then the length
of the side is actually going to be 4
root 2 plus 4 or 2 which is 8 square
root of 2 now all we have to do is
multiply that together so we have let's
see 1 half well let's do it like this 4
times 4 is 16 times 1/2 is 8 8 times 8
is 64 square root of 2 times square root
of 2 is 2 64 times 2 is a hundred and
twenty-eight and that's going to be C
this is centimeters so it's going to be
centimeters squared now remember with
multiplication you can do it in any
order I just did in a way that I thought
would be a little bit easier to do
without a calculator okay number 3 in
the comments below let me know how many
of these you were able to get right so
out of the 4 let me know but this one
we're given a regular pentagon and
they're giving us the apothem here so a
little bit different so you know
sometimes they give you the radius and
they give you the side links and I
didn't give you the perimeter sometimes
they give you the apothem but in all
these problems we can always use this
formula area equals 1/2 a times n times
s or area equals 1/2 times a times P but
the first thing I like to do is I like
to divide it up into congruent triangles
so see I'm drawing these radii like this
so you can see there's five sides so
there's gonna be five of these central
angles and if we take 360 degrees
divided by five that's going to give us
72 degrees for this central angle but
remember when you drop that apothem okay
that's going to bisect this central
angle meaning that's going to turn out
to be half which is 36 degrees so let me
just draw this triangle over here it's a
little bit bigger we can see it
- we said was 12 and let's see we've got
number of size which is 5 we just have
to find the length of the side so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna find this
side right here okay I'm just going to
call that axe but we're gonna have to
double it because you know we bisected
it when we drop the app Hotham so what
trig function now here we're doing sine
cosine and tangent or using our
trigonometry to find this missing side
which one should we use well remember
you always want to position yourself
over here at the angle and you've got
the opposite side and you have the
adjacent side so opposite and adjacent
that's going to be tangent so this is
going to be the tangent of 36 degrees
equals the opposite side x over the
adjacent side 12 it's always the second
over third in this sohcahtoa acronym if
we multiply both sides by 12 we can get
X by itself so let's go ahead and do
that in the calculator that's 12 tan 36
make sure you're in degree mode
and so this is coming out - I'm just
going to round a little bit here but
it's eight point seven one nine now I'm
gonna have to double that because we you
know we already cut it in half so we
need to double it to find the side
length so I'm going to say 2x is equal
to about 17 point four three seven so
that's our side length s seventeen point
four three seven and let's multiply this
together now a little hint because you
don't want to round and then round again
because you're gonna get what they call
a rounding error so I tend to take that
previous answer and carry it forward so
I'm gonna take this whole long decimal
I'm going to multiply it by five I'm
going to multiply it by 12 and I'm gonna
multiply it by a half and that comes out
to a little bit more accurate five
hundred twenty-three point one one and
we're just gonna say on this one units
squared because I didn't specify the
units okay if you're new to the channel
and we haven't met yet my name is Mario
of Mario's math tutoring and I tutor
students in person every single day so
what I try to do is take you know what I
learned from helping students and try to
distill it down and to make it easier
and I put those lessons and these videos
here trying to show you the different
techniques that make it easier to solve
these problems so I hope that's helping
you know my
for the channel is to make learning math
less stressful so you can raise your
grade past your class and go on to
pursue your dreams so let me know if
these videos are helping you but let's
do the last example here number 4 it
says find the area of a regular decagon
with the perimeter of a hundred
millimetres now a lot of students say
Mario I don't know how to draw a decagon
you know I don't even know how to draw
maybe a hexagon you don't actually have
to know how to draw any of these figures
what you can do is you can do something
like this see you can kind of almost
draw it like a circle okay regular
polygons kind of looks like a circle as
a number of sides increase and then
remember how we've been dividing up
these polygons into triangles kind of
like this you can keep going around and
make 10 of those or we really only need
one of them ok so we're just going to
focus on one of these triangles right
here and if I want to find that angle I
just have to use our formula 360 divided
by the number of these triangles which
is 10 and that's going to give us a
central angle of 36 degrees now if
you've been following along you notice
we always bisect that central angle we
cut it in half we drop that apothem
right the altitude of the triangle and
so now that means that this angle right
here is actually going to be 18 degrees
so let's go ahead and draw that triangle
a little bit larger over here it's got
an angle of 18 degrees and we know that
the perimeter is a hundred millimeters
all the way around well if there's 10
sides that means the side length of each
of these there's going to be 10 but when
we drop that altitude it's going to
bisect it or cut it in half that means
that each of these are going to be 5 and
so now what we can do is we can find the
apothem so again what I like to do is
like to start off by you know writing
the formula one half apothem times
perimeter I'm going to use this second
one in this case because they gave us
the perimeter is 100 millimeters so
let's go ahead and put that in the
apothem we don't know yet and then times
1/2 so what trig function ties together
this angle this side and this side
well it's tangent again because we have
opposite and adjacent so let's write
that down tangent of 18 degrees equals
opposite over adjacent and there's a
couple different ways to do this because
the variables in the denominator you can
this as being over 1 because anything
divided by 1 is itself you could cross
multiply and then solve it that way to
get rid of the fractions but there's a
little technique it's a property of
proportions where you can interchange
these on the diagonal so meaning I'm
going to put the a here a over 1 of
course is a and then this would be 5
over tangent of 18 so let's go to the
calculator on that and see what that
comes out to so 5 divided by the tangent
of 18 it's about fifteen point three
eight eight so let's write that down so
fifteen point three eight eight and now
we have everything that we need to find
the area again I'm just going to take
this long decimal that's on my
calculator and carry it forward by using
either the previous answer key or you
know carrying it out more decimal places
so it times a hundred times a half and
I'm getting about seven hundred and
sixty nine point four to not units but
in this case it's millimeters squared so
that's the area and you got it if you
want to see more examples
working with finding the area of a
regular polygon follow me over to that
video right there and we'll dive into
some more examples I'll see you in that
video